samantha ramsamy bonsoir la situation
est donc tendue actuellement en côte
d'ivoire est ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un petit point sur la situation
alors l'opposition vous savez vous
l'avez dit a rejeté le scrutin et a
annoncé justement hier la création d'un
conseil de transition civile sous la
houlette de pascal affi n'guessan avec à
sa tête l'ancien président henri
konan-bédié depuis dimanche les deux
leaders de l'opposition qui on le
rappelle ont boycotté le scrutin du
premier tour de cette présidentielle est
bien il multiplia les conférences de
presse nous étions nous avons assisté à
l'une d'entre elles dimanche lorsqu'ils
ont évoqué justement cette transition
civile et cet hiver qu'ils ont donc
annoncé la création d'un conseil de
transition civile
aujourd'hui encore il ya donc une
nouvelle conférence de presse qui s'est
tenue où les forces de l'ordre sur place
ont tiré des gaz lacrymogènes justement
va faire le point avec le porte parole
adjoint du gouvernement ivoirien
ministre de la jeunesse monsieur mamadou
touré que s'est il passé monsieur le
ministre
aujourd'hui mais le ministre de la
sécurité à communiquer là dessus
vous savez que dans cette période il a
été pris un acte d' interdiction donc de
manifestations sous l'essuie arue public
donc il s'agissait dans le contexte
particulier pour la police nationale
d'assurer la fluidité de la circulation
et donc il y avait des badauds dont des
malades du président henri konan bédié
et c'est pas ton été dispersés à coup de
gaz lacrymogènes à l'intérieur de la
résidence je le disais donc il y avait
eu un point presse qui était sur le
point de se tenir avec des journalistes
des journalistes qui ont filmé un peu ce
qui s'est passé à l'extérieur et
apparemment qui aurait été qu' on aurait
pris des caméras qu'on aurait aussi
empêché de participer à ce point presse
que répondez vous à cela
dans ces regrettables il n'est pas
notre intention d'empêcher et donc la
presse donc de faire son travail mais ce
que je peux dire c'est que au délà dont
10 qui s'est passé dans la résidence du
président henri konan bédié
l'acte posé par l'opposition hier
notamment l'appel à une transition avec
la mise en place d'un soi disant
gouvernement de transition pour nous est
une sédition élu ministre de la justice
n'ont qu'a pondu un communiqué au nom du
gouvernement qui annonce dans des
poursuites qui sont engagées contre les
auteurs de cette action
c'était lors d'un point presse ce matin
du gouvernement donc ça veut dire qu'on
s'achemine vers des arrestations des
leaders de ce gouvernement de transition
civile c'est à dire henri konan-bédié et
pascal affi n'guessan voilà donc un pays
au monde dans qu'un pays démocratique
donc un pays sûr yeux au monde ce genre
d'acte n'est tolérée on ne peut pas sur
une élection présidentielle qui a rénové
la légitimité du président sortant est
en violation de la constitution en
violation donc dû des principes même
démocratique annoncé la mise en place
d'un comité de transition avec un
gouvernement de transition c'est une
sédition et cela est puni par la loi
et quel que soit le niveau donc des
personnes qui s'adonnent à ce genre de
pratiques mais doit en assumer les
conséquences
pascal affi n'guessan son domicile que
se passe-t-il actuellement devant son
domicile parce que d'aider des vidéos
qui circulent que moi j'ai pu consulter
ou effectivement on voit des ddd crs des
gendarmes qui encercle son domicile
qu'en est il mais moi je n'ai pas
d'information précise sur la question
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
le gouvernement ivoirien a décidé les
saisit donc la justice et le procureur
de la république pour donc
porter plainte contre tous ceux qui ont
décidé donc en violation comme je le dis
encore une fois de la constitution de
mettre en place un comité de transition
avec un gouvernement de transition c'est
c'est inacceptable mais ça veut dire
qu'on se dirige donc vers des
arrestations et peut-être un assaut de
cette résidence d'henri konan bédié
parce qu'il ya des militants et lui et
ses militants aussi les leaders du pdci
il faut laisser la justice faire son
travail à partir du moment où le
procureur de la république a été saisi
il reviendra au procureur à partie des
éléments d'information qui dans sa
disposition de voir quelles sont les
voies et les procédures donc à utiliser
ce que je paie des couleurs des équipes
de henri konan-bédié hier je les ai eus
au téléphone ils m'ont affirmé qu'il y
avait eu des tirs de sommation devant
leur domicile qu'ils ont même fait
trembler les vitres
est ce que c'est la réalité il accuse
les crs mais ce que je vous ai dit
madame et qui a été dit par louisa
sécurité donc il ya eu donc et gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser des badauds
qui était devant sa résidence alors ils
ont manipulé notamment quitte à jouer en
faisant croire qu'ils avaient des arbres
y avait des ti à la lourde mais une âme
aux tirs et sur un bâtiment détruit le
bâtiment elles régalé le bâtiment donc
de répondre à béziers pour essayer d
impact et d'armes lourdes
il s'agissait donc de lacrymogènes pour
disperser les badauds regroupés doigt la
résidence donc de l'ex-président est ce
qu'on peut espérer mais ses ministres
une main tendue de la parade alassane
ouattara évidemment il faut attendre que
la cour constitutionnelle le confirme
confiant dans sa victoire mais le
présentateur a été constant dans sa main
tendue il ya un an et demi on le répète
à souhait de pezens ouattara a décidé
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec l'opposition
pour préparer le scrutin
à quelques jours de la présentielle à
deux fois sur deux semaines le
gouvernement a appelé l'opposition toute
la table de discussion de vous lui aurez
remarqué que depuis un an on a une
position qui s'est radicalisée qui a
refusé toutes les mains tendues même
temps le goût fait plus de flexibilité
pour accepter la recomposition des
commissions locales
ils ont réfusé donc la main tendue du
président ouattara
est toujours de mise parce que nous
disons c'est que tout dialogue doit se
fait dans un cadre républicain et tout
dialogue doit respecter donc l'ordre
constitutionnel
or cette opposition radicale s'est mise
en tête donc d'une autre
constitutionnelle ce qui est totalement
inacceptable
ses bras de fer aucun politique auquel
on assiste entre l'opposition et le
pouvoir qui s'est durci ou est-ce qu'il
peut mener aujourd'hui la côte d'ivoire
parce que les ivoiriens sont très
inquiet ils sont inquiets face à un
nouveau cycle de violence que cela peut
entraîner
mais je leur assurer que où l'on bien
compris parce que la quiétude des
populations ou listées aux amateurs
étaient de dire ce qu'on va pas revivre
2010 ou de constater qu'il ya eu des
violences qui ont certainement émaillé
donc cette présence y est restée isolée
et cie construit dans les passions de
l'opposition et cela n'avait rien à voir
avec la violence généralisée dont de
2010 nous avons des fraudeurs qui ont
fait preuve donc de professionnalisme
malgré les agressions à leur encontre
est il des manifestants armés ont tiré
sur des policiers sur des gendarmes dans
cette situation est gérée de façon très
professionnelle je peux vous rassurer
que justement c'est pour éviter que le
pays plonge donc dans une crise sans
précédent que nous ne pouvons pas donner
laisser-faire donc ce qui manifestement
ont des projets funestes et qui veulent
mettre la république à genoux c'est
inacceptable et cela ne sera pas accepté
donc dialogue oui mais dans le cadre
d'un cadre républicain respectueux
l'état de droit et de notre hôte
constitutionnel tous ceux qui vont se
mettre en marge de cela madame
répondront de voir la justice
merci messieurs ministre d'avoir répondu
à nos questions voilà pour la situation
sur les tensions apolitique qui se
durcissent ici en côte d'ivoire si
beaucoup
samantha ramsamy pour toutes ces
précisions merci également à cléricaux
qui vous accompagnent du côté d'abidjan